a lot of people are asking me the new
paid deal does he get the retain like
doesn't say doesn't get there but buzzy
there is a clear sense in the question
that he must not but how did I know that
without it telling me okay so number one
it's like it's a new thing like the
rules are off I'm now setting a new
being Joyce just another reason right if
if the beta strike is 8% plus 200 if
there was 10% and the existing 300 it's
not even a question
it's like is a bigger or 10 bigger but
that's not the question
the point is it's a risky idea Lizabeth
the new deal it's riskier if he sells
more he stands to gain more but he
doesn't have that safety blanket the
retain more he has a bad month then it's
not gonna get comfortable right so that
is why this is a comparison that's how
we use the language of the question to
be able to tell even though it doesn't
spell out explicitly he doesn't get a
retainer you can deduce that he doesn't
get it
all right which is just about right for
look so wanna suggest to me some part
says what's in this out
what's he saying your salary
eighty-three nine yeah and how's it
hangin number right
okay good just this 52 times we keep it
that okay his hourly rates is how we
write what did you get for that 1770
employment run if I recall those
surrounding as well okay now before we
get to the Roundy where's this number
rise from like what calculations you do
to get there good you start from the
same thing this weekly rate what you're
dividing instead of multiplying because
you want to think about a smaller time
unit it's not a bigger one
what's the actual number of trailing off
you zero 17.15 seven so that's all you
need to know right sevens going to go up
it's clearly closer to 16 cents let's
continue
okay and the depot is you should be
rounded to the years okay
no lemurs mother what do you think of
its activation ok she's wrong right now
before we get to why she's wrong how did
you know that she was wrong because says
explained using calculations yeah
yeah okay good good so if you take these
switches the entire year right now
because you want to go to monthly you
divide by 12 it's so wise I don't get
why that's different okay
really any question so what is she
actually done like how did she this is
the question overalls down how did she
arrive at 2007 it's not rain enough oh
yeah okay so she's taking this ml you
multiply that by 4 you get 2,600 pays
okay now what's aware of my 4 is not an
unusual thing to do because there are
about four weeks in a month right but um
but there are exactly four weeks a month
and in fact every month is a different
length so if you want to do it's like
number of which you can't really do that
it's their regular number of weights per
month so that's why you've got to go all
the way up to here it's always going to
be conservative and then you have to
come back to month by / 12 right you'll
find that in fact if we wanted to go
from this directly to monthly pay
instead of multiplying by four we're
going to be multiplying by 52 on 12 now
you can kind of see the comparison now
but you right 52 on 12 what would it be
if we multiply by 4 that would be 48 on
12 right so you'll be missing those few
weeks that's why I think if I call her
calculation is less than you can't pay a
bit less then because we have more than
four weeks in every month even husband
so important by the way I'll just come
back to this word in a minute what is
explained using calculation so what I'm
expecting that you have is you calculate
of what the actual monthly pay is by
doing this division and then you say
well there's a discrepancy of what was
it as busy
yeah like what was the a chronometer
does ok says job back oh cool quick
bucks that's a fib ugh
okay now for Part B this time bother to
skip the answers
I'd love some working so what would
somebody suggested their first line what
do they actually put down to argue
further one or the other
begins a person okay
so let's just pause for a minute this is
perfect in the brackets help us
understand there's two different pieces
here not to be confused what are the two
pieces Commission here and retain their
good okay I'm going to add one piece of
efficient before this because I'm about
to do a new equation as well one okay
Clara Kia is the original scheme like
what he's currently gone right so I'm
gonna call this all pain
right because that's done that's what it
used to be what is this number
what is it 920 now this point hopefully
your spider sense is tingling and you
can actually already see that the news
situation is gonna be it done right can
you see it because 10 percents an easy
number to work out 10% with nothing else
10% of 9,000 is just going to be yeah
see you're sure right we do want to show
that that because it says give reasons
for your answer some expecting that most
if you can say something like this
you pay equals you're going to do the
Commission and there's nothing else but
I want to be able to that up off my
numbers and look I'm not just making
this up it's better to stay with okay
make sense now just a quick question
just extend and lock into another board
but what would have to change in order
to make the new situation actually
better than the old situation like it's
20 dollars difference right now what
would have to change which improve
absurd so the easy thing is well if you
give me a $20 retainer I'll be fine but
they're kind of ignores like you know
what kind of a person would say yes to
this deal and no to this one like what's
a retainer about you it's about
stability it's not saying look there's
going to be some bad months okay now if
I'm a person to you like maybe what is
he does it say what he sells um suppose
I know what he's selling so it's like a
condition like that and the weather is
getting warmer and warmer and I know I'm
gonna sell a lot more in the coming
months right if I'm more confident in my
sales then I want a bigger percentage
right like I think everyone sees they
find a huge number
like our new via dollars or something
like that if those are the sales is $200
is like nothing it just it vanishes away
it's trivial that's the way about mrs.
she what's that
so these kinds of things we call the
breakeven points right it's like if he
increases the amount that he sells on
them per week at some point they'll be
exactly the same like whichever scheme
growing on and it tossed that it's
better to have no original